Alexis you wrote an article for film
courage wrote a few one of which was
play your cards right I think it was
from March of last year you give ten
tips first one get involved to do it for
free do projects you have to finish be
open to collaboration say yes which is a
running theme and I like that theme it's
great promote yourself at some point
start getting paid which I think that
can hear the cheers coming play your
cards right don't get distracted and
enjoy yourself and be inspired which one
of those ten do you think is the most
crucial besides getting paid everyone
was the guinea pig um Oh which would I
say is the most crucial or are they all
necessary maybe they're all part they've
all been important to me I think him one
of the things doing projects you have to
finish for me is particularly important
just because I i tried i remember when i
was trying to do be a dance music artist
and I had so many tracks I'd never
finish so that was that concern me and
once and I remember the first time it
talks about it in the article actually
the first time that I had to finish a
project was for this one hour 20 silent
film a classic silent film called south
and I I mean I had to write an hour and
20 minutes are never as an hour and 20
minutes of music in my life and I
committed to it and I did it and it went
into a brochure that it was going to be
happening and the ticketing was done and
I realized it just it just changed I
think from that point on it changed my
whole approach to things you know and
you have a deadline when you have to do
something because I wouldn't I'm not
very good at setting myself deadlines I
always say to myself not going to rush
this project not going to rush out I'm
going to get it all done and you get the
most stressful stuff done at least a
month and a half before and then it's a
week and a half an hour
gosh I still haven't done this I still
haven't that I still haven't done this
so I mean actually think what else on
there is really will be open to
collaboration I find that interesting
because do you think sometimes it's
better to do things yourself I know you
said that you brought in someone great
from Barclays that helped out and really
was it was a strong person in that
project what do you think sometimes it's
better to just have it be your own
vision or is that may be too selfish
maybe that's the wrong attitude it's
it's too many cooks in the kitchen you
do need to keep your own vision i I've
worked a lot with the two people that
have been like my mentors have been
professor at wada maranda at Plymouth
University he runs the research group
the interdisciplinary Center computing
music research and Simon eyeball who's
the director of music at Plymouth
University now I've worked a lot with
Simon eyeball because he takes what are
sometimes quite geeky and impractical
ideas and he says how can we make this
presentable to an audience and not just
to it not just to an audience of
computer music geeks but to a broader
audience to anyone is interested Simon's
very much into kind of getting the
community interest in the general public
interested in what's being done and
introducing something slightly new now
sometimes he would say what about if we
did it this way and a lot of the time
I'd be like yes good yeah I remember one
that might break through peace sunlight
Symphony which the first time I got in
the media like nationally a few times
for that my original plan was because
what happened in sunlight symphony is
you put light sensors on this huge
building and they were connected to a
computer music instrument and what would
happen is the Sun rose over Plymouth my
hometown it would play the instabuilder
like a musical instrument so it's called
sunrise Symphony and you'd hear this
music getting louder and more complex as
there as the lobby of the building got
lighter now my original plan was this
piece would be 24 hours a day 365 days a
year where
thirty two light sensors and Simon able
said to me can you do with eight light
sensors in half an hour sure and I said
I i I've I can't remember I probably
flustered I've had a half are maybe yeah
but I thought I thought well this is a
heck of an opportunity you know this is
I once again I was in the first year or
so of my career people tended to think
of me as a scientist and the
technologist and wouldn't rather than an
artist and I thought I've just got to
say yes I've got to say yes to this and
it was any thing is with it it didn't
compromise the core of the vision and
this is what I've and the core of the
vision was son plays a building like a
musical instrument as it rises that's
that was the core of the vision and it's
been the same with a lot of my pieces a
lot of my performances or the film
there's been a heart of the piece which
has come from my heart and which I will
defend as my job to defend it because
what Isis there's a temptation is there
a temptation it's not really been a
temptation but one possible route with a
piece is when it gets really hard that
you compromised me a lot like the heart
of the project but what's the point I'm
not in this I know sometimes people
think I'm a massive self publicist and I
just like to have my name in the papers
or whatever but it's not that I like I
do like my name in the papers but I like
my project I it's my projects a part of
me it's me and my project seeing that
recognized is important to me and
therefore what the project is is
important to me so if I haven't defended
the heart of it and sometimes I've had
collaborators by meaning than the name
is there I've said to them I will call
it by me in you this performance this
project I'll says by me and you and I've
had them say the week before when it's
going is really getting bad similar we
could just fake this bit or we could
just drop that bitter there and I've I'm
not a great people person like I said
I'm not a great negotiator
so that's one of the things but I just
know I just have to say I have to say to
them probably with a similar tone of
voice that I said to Simon eyeball or
the director of music you know what
maybe can we just keep it the same way
you know this time defending the heart
of the project I find it very hard to do
I hate conflict hate conflict so but
you've got to do it otherwise what's the
point if I lose the heart of the project
what's the point and my job is to know
the diff one of my job's is no
difference between the heart and the
stuff that can be compromised
you